a vehicle jika is a former first wave
division agent who has joined forces
with Aaron kena when the government
collapsed during the outbreak he went
rogue and his loyalty now goes to
whoever will feed his need for blood
[Music]
[Music]
aviary jika was born in Belen New Mexico
he was an operative of the Joint Special
Operations Command Brewer was a blackops
hitman for the US government kojiki was
eventually recruited by the strategic
homeland division for his vast
experience technical skills and his
resilience when under pressure however
there were some questions regarding a
psychological evaluation all the boxes
are me and spec ops background strong
work ethic multiple decoration and
letters of recommendation his psych eval
is inconclusive what does that even mean
it means we don't know what's going on
inside his head it means for all we know
a little pressure and he'll snap did you
even read his reports he's been through
hell and back if he's going to snap he
would have already I'm just saying it's
a risk it could just be really good at
hiding his flaws look can we get a
second opinion I really don't want to
throw this guy out on the whims of one
psychologist I'll take care of him
regardless of the concerns in the end
kojiki was selected as a division agent
cogeco was activated in New York City
after the Dola flu outbreak to assist
the JTF in maintaining control of the
quarantine zone in Manhattan given his
black ops experience he was considered
to be a true asset to the divisions
first wave although he had the utmost
confidence that he and his fellow first
wave agents would get the job done
through any means necessary he had some
strong doubts about the JTF immediately
the JTF will liaise with the division
they're inexperienced can we trust them
to fall in line there is no falling in
line they are the locals and we are the
outsiders being local doesn't mean
they'll make the right decisions
emotional attachments cloud better
judgment which is why we need to
- what they have to say get on their
good side and make sure the transition
runs as smoothly as possible
it's no secret that the good people of
New York have struggled to contain this
thing they care about this city it's our
job to support them and keep it from
falling apart we'll get the job done but
I'm not depending on people who are
already starting to crack when the
operation failed and the government
would drew the JTF
and started evacuating the quarantine
zone Kouji could continue to work
through saving as many civilian lives as
possible
however he eventually found himself
trapped by hostile forces while leading
a group of civilians to safety could you
could put an urgent request through to
the JTF command back you should - what
we've called an evacuation order we need
to finish this sorry in motion nothing
left but a couple of stragglers you
can't just leave it's over agent I'm not
having any more death on my conscience
I should have no you [ __ ] us if we stay
we're dead if we leave we're rogue I'm
sorry agent there's nothing I can do oh
well [ __ ] kojiki OHS request was denied
he was left with the decision to either
stay and die or escape abandoning the
civilians in turn being mocked as rogue
by Isaac
coochie-coo was furious at the JTF and
the government betrayal hell-bent on
revenge he would choose to use as years
of training and experience inspirations
to find and kill all of those who are
responsible for leaving it behind
so you absolve yourself of
responsibility helped people by
sacrificing others you people don't
deserve this city I can make this right
it's too late for that
please since you're so intent on passing
the blame I'm gonna need some names
aaron kena well aware of the situation
in background suka jika is a valuable
asset and his mission against the
government kena promise go chica in
return for doing his bidding that he
would supply him with the details of the
people involved with making the
decisions on the day that the JTF was
told to evacuate the quarantine zone as
a down payment kena provided him for the
JT of officer to kill on sight what do
you want now I want to make sure our
paths align the traitors and deserters
who abandon us in the dark zone you want
the dead so do i I'm tracking them down
with my Intel connections you don't have
to I'm doing this my way kena I give you
access to the cleaners all you have to
do is guide them the right direction
you're working down here they're working
down here as well work together what do
you get out of it I don't get my hands
dirty and him consider him a pen pal
so we have a deal
following on from this kena approached
rogue agent Vivian Connelly he wanted to
jika to have access to the cleanest so
he could utilize them in his mission to
work with chika it's not about what I
want it's about what we need he's got
resources we can exploit I don't like
the idea of working with someone on
vigilante crusade that's irrelevant he
wants the JTF out of the picture the
cleaners need the same thing it will
benefit the cleaner him which is why I
need you with me on this one he's like
you he's dedicated nothing like me look
if we're so close to achieving what
we've been talking about with cogeco on
board we can finally make it happen I
trust him to deliver on his end he will
help us succeed you vouch for him
responsibility although apprehensive at
first kena managed to persuade oh it
wasn't particularly smooth sailing from
here though her chicas mission and the
methods towards achieving it clashed
quite heavily with the way that the
cleaners worked he was repeatedly
questioned after asking for the support
of what you would usually respond in
threats at all they're treating the
infected we'll do what needs to be done
but on our terms
you have mine I said on our terms bran
damage control
we're not here to pick up your dry
cleaning this is non-negotiable you
should respect that
KYNA ordered to chica along with fellow
rogue agents vivian connelly james drag
off and theo Parnell to assault the JTF
base of operations in lower Manhattan
City Hall he was given the job of
eliminating the JTF guards on site while
Conley set up keenest explosive virus
devices on the structural pillars the
division agents arrived from Washington
DC and investigated the attack while
there they found evidence pointing
directly to a vehicle chica along with
his fellow rogue agent co-conspirators
which proved that they were the ones
behind the attacks after further
investigation it was determined that
they were in fact working with kina of
the course of time coochie-coo was
tracked down and was found to be
residing in the Battery Park District
through the Intel gathered by the
peacekeepers he was found to be located
at Hugh Carey tunnel the division headed
to the site were greeted by a large
group of cleaners kojiki then taunted
the agents by executing a hostage in
front of them before disappearing into
the compound the division caught up with
him again but this time he had the
company of the cleaners after a quick
assault the division managed two special
cleaners but cogeco escaped further into
the tunnels the agents pursued but their
attention was drawn towards a cleaner
operation to attack Haven using a huge
drill called Nancy already granted
apparently was cagey cos idea then I
left to get started right away how long
how long will it take to get me ten good
engineers already done and I'll leave a
backup crew to take care of a
disturbances Nancy's bound to attract
some attention once she gets going Nancy
Nancy gets us where we need to go she
always got a name they ride again the
division made short work of this
operation eliminating the cleaner guards
and disabling the drill Nettie
but there seemed to be kuchiki's planned
to distract the agents while he prepared
his defenses the division and kojiki
were to face off in a boiler room using
the steam to his advantage
coochie-coo was able to force the agents
into attacking under his terms but the
agents were too strong and were able to
flip control disabling the steam and
forcing him to meet them on equal
grounds in a last-ditch effort
coochie-coo rushed towards the agents to
engage them in hand-to-hand combat but
before he could reach them he was gunned
down kojiki smartwatch was taken by the
division and was handed to fail out on
their return she would use this to
assist in locating Aaron kena
a vehicle Chico was wise to Akina was
doing with the other rogue agents
manipulating them into doing his bidding
but because keno was providing him with
the Intel that he needed to enact his
revenge he played along tajikistan the
government were actually very similar to
kinas left behind while trying to rescue
civilians forced to make a choice
between staying and dying or going rogue
the only difference being that kojiki
just wanted revenge on those who made
the calls
whereas keno seems to just want to watch
the world burn
Kouji Kasturi is one of the more
straightforward out of the four rogue
agents that weiner brought on board
although on paper he was more qualified
based on his past and skill sets that he
brought to the table he seemed to be an
odd choice based on his psych evaluation
and he's certainly not the first one
that has managed to slip through the
recruitment process despite obvious
potential to create issues in the future
anyway thank you very much for watching
I'm still missing a bit of intel on drag
off and Conley but I'll be getting these
ones out very soon so we can start
discussing some of the more pressing
questions like are the shd really the
good guys at the stage catch you on the
next one
Cheers
[Music]
you
[Music]